I really love jeopardy but I've
mentioned this before and I hate to say
it but I am starting to think Alex
Trebek has been hosting that show too
long he's been doing it a long time and
just watching the show recently I'm
starting to think he's losing it I
really do take a look
rhyme for six Bill Murray and Matt Damon
reproduce asexually by means of this
body part with a longer shaft to
stabilize your foot that will be Tabasco
sauce pasta
Andrew court appointees for 1,000 Lady
Gaga's hog choker cuts off the ear of a
man named orange juice while her arms
reach down to grasp the Thunderball what
is can do and do back to you Bible for
Steven Tyler is said to frequent the
children's dungeon using an orangutan
named zubenelgenubi to disinfect
communists mattresses would be the
Yakuza biblical Anatomy for 200
ding-dong shakespeare's unicorn gets
house visits from a naked baby splayed
on the hood of a Ferrari
calling for Brotherhood between
Christians and Hitler what is a
midsummer night's dream house
[Applause]